unlike last week I decided to make a
little change on the advice of some
people at the club last time I showed
you some theoretical positions and I
figured it sometimes other other
instructors also show it to you and then
there's some repetition this time I kind
of try to do something that is not your
typical book like winner but rather
examples that are typical of certain
endings so we're going to do a few porn
endings we're going to do a few Rock
endings and then I'm going to show you a
position that is a queen versus two
rooks and talk a little about that so
we'll start with some porn and eggs and
I will have to assume that most of you
all of you already know how to win king
and pawn versus scheme last time I was
talking about it and I was mentioning
how when the pawn is on the same level
of the king or behind the king then it's
always a draw on an empty board king
important and how if the king is in
front of the pond then whoever has the
opposition gets his way so sometimes
it's a win and sometimes it's a draw and
it's important for our pond linings
otherwise if you don't know it's a bit
hard so we'll start with this position
this is a really great composition I
wish I remember who compose it because I
usually like to give credit but I don't
have it and this is why to move it looks
like white is completely lost but porn
endings are the work of the devil if you
are wrong by one tempo then a wind can
turn into a loss and and sometimes you
can save lost position you see in in the
ending books you can see many
grandmasters really losing their way in
pawn amex here after cup when you look
at the position it looks like it's
resigning time from white how can you
possibly save the position Black has two
good bones and the blocking easily stops
the white pawn so still you will see
that there's a tricky way and again it's
based on knowing the opposition to make
a drawer here so of course you'll see
that the white just plays let's say okay
let's say the first move is the same and
of course black has to defend this pawn
and let's pretend that white will now go
backwards or something then of course
it'll be a technical whim or for example
make let me make
even more challenging like let's say
here and the blocking goes here let's
say white marks time waiting and black
is attacking the pawn and wife has to
defend upon could have also been from
this direction and now d5 and white has
to let go of the point of course he
loses right so regular means there's no
way for white to save the game however
from the starting position like we said
the way to do it is actually the
paradoxical sacrificing of his own porn
so temporarily white is going to be done
two pawns but is going to save a drawer
again basting on your position so King
at five well in one second i will take
the poll on f6 then it'll be black wise
to worry about the draw Sookie g7 the
only move again it looks like white is
just lost any key retweet and again buck
is going to go kia fate and kini seven
just like we saw however e7 king f7
again black looks really confident again
it's just about to take the poll only
seven after which is going to be down to
point but white plays the surprising EA
equals queen check you must take and
black must be still really confident
that he's going to win the game because
after King takes f6 Kingda seven and
King c6 he is going to get the position
where he has the opposition with the key
in front of the pawn as all of you must
know by now however white plays the
wonderful move king ECX again sometimes
it's really such a paradoxical decision
you're so hungry to take the pawn you
think I'm down two pawns in the pond
ending what can be more alarming than
that but then kini six and now basically
any black move is going to be a draw
because if you go this way then of
course I'm going to take this born and
if you go the other way I'm going to
take the other pond and any attempt in
pushing the one of the points forward
I'm just going to be in a simple king
behind this pawn ending let's say for
example this then I take in here I can
afford to let go of the opposition for a
moment because the position of the pawn
and after keeney six king of four with a
simple draw right we know already we
discussed that last week
to hear I wait when you show yourself
opposition all the way down the board
where its stomach ok so again notice the
importance of opposition's in pawn
endings ok example number two
let's see let's see let's do this one
okay this one actually comes with a
little story very short story that
sometimes people ask me hey Aviv how
many moves ahead can you see in a chess
game that is of course a very difficult
question I think one of the masses of
the past maybe it was dark over at our
show said that the only always sees just
one move but it's the best move but
that's kind of a smart aleck answer the
correct answer it really depends on the
position in some complicated positions
if you could see two three moves ahead
you are really lucky and in some
positions you can see many many moves
ahead so I like to give this position as
a homework position as a no more
exercise homework exercise to my
students and I insist that they come up
only with a complete and full solution
and this is an example that you can
really calculate an ending for a very
very long time so you look at the
position and again when you take the
first look you think that white is not
happy it looks like right now because
it's right to move that means that black
has the opposition and whichever side
black white chooses like if you go
skiing left to d3 then there's going to
be a capture and the king is going to
penetrate or if you go this way then the
king is going to go to d4 the blocking
is going to d4 looks very gloomy okay
what's more if you play pawn takes pawn
on g5f takes g5 and black has the
outside pass porn which is going to rush
down the board by the time the White
King is going to try to stop it black is
going to take the pawn and then grow
munch on the other ponds with a very
easy win however when we talk about
outside passed pawns now it's white
stone to create a pass form so this is
the kind of answer that you see that
everything is kind of forced now I'm not
giving you any time and you're trying to
solve it so I'm not really being fair to
you but you can imagine that you had
ample time at home to look at it you
probably would come up with some if not
all of the solution so of course the
first move has to be g4 again somewhat
paradoxical but when you look at it you
start to understand what this is really
it's working it's really a good move now
the simple thing is that I just want to
take on h5 and then wash my pawn notice
that the black king has a little problem
with the Queen Square because this
is not letting him cross and his own
porn is in the way as well on f6 well
that's bad news so what did you the only
move of course to keep fighting is to
take that pawn on g4 if you for example
try to take here and I'm going to take
here then it becomes obvious that this
is just a technical win while this king
is going to try to rush and stop the
pawn I'm just going to come here and at
leisurely munch the spawn then even if I
pitch the h-bond I'm going to win the
game by taking all the other ponds that
is really easy so again we're going to
try to be more challenging with HT hg
for and now the point h5 now black has a
little bit of a headache trying to stop
the pond but he can he can still stop it
he's not losing because of that pond yet
he has two ways to play the first one is
the short answer if he tries to play f5
the idea of course is that he's going to
get his King into the box quickly so
like but of course if pond takes King
takes is no good solution so watch what
why does he allows blood to have a nice
balance of pawns running down the board
which is not going anywhere and in
exchange is going to have two points
that are remote from one another and
that's going to drive the black king
crazy watch h6 beautiful so now of
course you cannot afford to play a move
like this because then I'm just going to
take the pawn and you are stuck you
cannot take the pawn because I'll push
the h-bomb and you cannot come to the h1
now my king is just going to play
pac-man is going to come here here eat
eat eat everything so instead black
needs to try the check tempo and the
King goes back and now i'm about to play
87 so you better do something productive
you have to go here and now i'm going to
play check and that's what I promise you
the two pawns are driving the black king
crazy notice that those three pawns are
very nice they look really impressive
but they're not self-supporting you can
give me one check and I'm going to move
my king that's it they cannot queen so
of course you'd have to try to stop the
porn somehow by going here then
just going to keep pushing the pawn and
the King has a serious problem not being
able to be at two places at the same
time of course white is winning right
does everybody understand that yeah I
think that's self-explanatory so his
other try was to play in the game king
e6 and now why it simply Corral's the
Jeep one and regains the pony sacrifice
so we go here here here here here here
so far I think that this was reasonable
to calculate right one side sacrificed
the pawn he had to accept it I started
pushing the point in order to clean it
he had to try and chase it to stop it in
the meantime I use the time to regain my
sacrifice pawn now it's right to move
any has to let go of his h-bond but this
is the advantage of having an outside
passport because you are faster look at
what happens King f5 key takes h5 King
takes f6 block is also running with a
passed pawn unfortunately white Queens
will check and watch what happened now g
4 a 5 g 3 e 6 g to e 7 g 1 queen e 8
Queens with Chuck now you cannot come
here because this is made you cannot go
to g4 because i'm going to go King to g8
quinta g8 and pick up your queen so you
only move is king here and now white
goes again into a pond ending check
check takes me up again upon ending and
now we see the difference the white king
is not only one file closer but it's
also his move he wins the game
beautifully kini 5 king of to King Here
Kim Here Kim Here Kim Here takes here
here here here here and just as black is
ready to play King c4 and draw the game
white players King b5 and by one tempo
he won the initial position by one tempo
exactly so if you can see the solution
if you can see the number is 21 moves
deep but
most of my students almost at all level
levels when they get it at home and they
have enough time to think about it by
trial and error they get the solution
because again it's kind of
self-explanatory okay so we are done
with this one and now we are going to do
some rook endings which are some of my
favorites let's see i have actually I've
several of them but one of them I guess
I didn't open or I already closed let's
start with okay let's start with my own
ending actually I have to get rid of
this time there we go this is a game I
played many many years ago against
another feeding master and in this
position white is up a pawn in the
ending but as a matter of fact this is
not very easy to win as you can see if
white doesn't do anything productive
right now black is going to play the
move be four then it's going to play the
move be three and that point is going to
need serious babysitting because else
it's going to Queen so I have to do
something about that on the other hand I
need to think how am I going to win
right being stopping the pawn is one
thing but how am I going to materialize
my advantage well notice that I have
four against two on the King side and
especially the pawn on e5 looks very
impressive right now by itself with the
rookie cannot do anything like if I go
check e7 is just not not very useful so
what to do in this position the first
move is forced really really forced and
I was very proud of myself being able to
calculate it in advance I think that if
I would not have found that move then
probably I would never transpose to this
rook ending and that was actually the
only way to win the game so i'll share
with you and i'll try to explain Luke a
six step number one the rook is
paralyzing both pawns by being here now
of course if you play the move be four
I'm just going to take the pond on a for
now up two pawns this is going to be
really a walk in the park right it's
going to be super easy so now by one
move unfreezing both pawns and now i'm
ready for my own action which will you
will see how that was done in the game
so my opponent here played the move g5
because he realized
that now my intention is very simple I
want to play f4 then I want to play g4
then I want to play f5 and then with two
pawns in the rock it's going to be very
easy to push the King backwards and it's
going to win by cleaning the pond and
putting the king in a making map so you
play g5 and not a try would have been to
play the move rook c8 that would have
been very very interesting and in this
position again why this to be a little
careful because of course the rook is
coming to visit on c2 but King d3 a very
very good move and again my plan is very
simple I want to push the Jeep on and
the f1 I don't care what you do so let's
say check King III again taking control
of the second rank now if black wants to
play the move rook c8 again trying to
get to see to notice that my king
already improved this position it's on
III so I'm not going to be checked if
you go there and I can just stop pushing
my pawns so for example g4 say you go
here for example F for let's say you
take the pawn f5 you can see that now
material is even but while the white
pawns are very well advanced the black
bones are still kind of stuck and my
next move is going to be rook a seven
keep pushing those bones and it's going
to be just too late for those bonds are
not well advanced then it's going to be
too much so for example let's say here
and I will play check you have to go
backwards either to e8 or f8 I don't
think it really matters then I will play
something like f6b 3 e 6 and the mate on
a eight besides the game so just a
question of speed so something to
remember in this position and in all
rock endings you know the two things
about rook endings one of them is the
funny and generic that says all rook
endings are drawn that's what people
said because it's so hard to win rock
endings obviously it takes very little
to just change something and an opponent
Vantage's us not enough the second
saying that are much more in love wit i
should say is that in rook endings the
placement of the pieces is more
important than the number of the pawns
in other words
have to count porn sure if somebody's up
six months chances are you will win
right but if there's like one or two
point advantage it's really important to
see where the pieces are if for example
one king is up the middle of the board
it like let's say the 5th or 6th rank
and the other one is boxed into the last
rank and let's say there's one look
who's very active and cutting him off
and the other rookies just roaming
somewhere then you can even be down
material down one or two points or
especially even material and it wouldn't
matter the placement of your pieces is
going to decide the outcome and this is
one of those positions it's not so much
the extra point that I have for example
the a two point is not super valuable
but the fact that I'm having my rookie
is cutting the king of this point is
advanced and my King has a free roam
down the board so after g5 I played King
III rook here Keeney 4 i'm just bitching
all my pawn she can take all my pawns
because again I'm going to win with just
my advanced pawn in my rock so he played
here King a five again this proves the
statement that I made before the
placement of the pieces is much more
important than the number of the pawns
he can take all the pawns on the second
rank but he won't be able to stop my
pawn & ok he starts taking good for him
check the King has to go backwards here
if he goes King f8 it's even easier
because then I play king of six
threatening mate so he goes here and now
I'm just advancing my king again he can
take all the ponds that he wants he
realized that I'm threatening to play
six so he tried to apply here for a
moment you might say WOW Aviv not only
did you give your pawn back but you're
about to lose another pond we check for
example if you play e6 rook takes f3
check and you are you're worse but again
in positions like this the pawn is so
advanced the king is so advanced the win
is just their root ka check king d7 e6
check now I'm interested in pushing the
pond to e7 so King d6 praying that maybe
i will blunder with e7 and then rook
takes f3 and i have to let go of the
pond but why
wins with rook v8 king c7 e7 game over
after work to xf3 i can take the poll on
g5 or if i'm in the mood i can just play
here just so he doesn't check me anymore
and I'm winning of course the pawn is
unstoppable did you guys understand
awesome okay so we are done with that
okay this is one of the first rook
endings that I that I studied many many
years ago and it's quite famous you can
see it in books and you can see it in
lectures if some of you recognize it i
won't be surprised I was really amazed
to see how with so little material and
with the porn split and the blacking
claiming some stake in the center also
there's a d5 pawn in the center how on
earth can something like this be winning
for one side looks like just a simple
draw who can believe that from a
position like this why can practically
force black to lose both his pawns which
it looks looks almost paradoxical looks
ridiculous right looks like I'm making a
statement like a not bad let's talk
about why is white winning in this
position again the placement of the
pieces the rook is behind his porn and
that rook is very passively blocking it
which means any remove my point is going
to keep pushing and again keeping in
mind that many porn earnings are going
to be one blacks hands are tied what to
do now black is probably seeking some
activity for example may be king before
King b3 and tickling this porn can you
imagine then he's going to start pushing
his beep on and well he might get
countered by so in this position someone
like Lasker he was a world champion for
27 years he is not going to miss this
idea first move rook f4 cutting the King
off and of course if the blocking comes
backwards then my king wants to step in
the white idea is just to chase the rock
in other words if i can get king d for
King e5 and then f6 f7 I'm just going to
win the game pros eyes so black tries to
play his best chance pawn to b4 again
the ball is in white squirt what to do
white plays a very very quiet move pawn
be three the idea is to freeze the black
pawn for moving period notice that now
he is kind of running out of moves he
has real issues if you place the move d4
with the idea that every book takes he
will lose this bond yeah in your dreams
right then after D for King efore can
you all see that if the Pawn groves to
d4 white goes kini for game over I'm
just going to go key five or I'm going
to win the pawn so he has to play this
move this is a kind of a clever move he
moves the brook 1 square trying to
provoke the pawn to advance because
knowing maybe then the black king and
the black hook and correlate maybe he
can win it in some positions of course
white calculated that he goes here King
d6 king d for King e6 and in this
position again it's a question of
calculation what to do how to how to win
the game so again white plays a very
simple move look the f1 the rook is done
with his job of cutting the King on the
fourth-ranked and now he is challenging
black to say ok you have a chance to be
up material if you feel like it take my
pawn but obviously you cannot do that if
he takes the pawn then after takes takes
takes and you can already see we're
going to have a pawn ending with a very
easy win after here here here here here
just when you're good and ready to go
King b6 and again the opposition
surprise I already have the opposition
and I'm clearing the way to the pawn
just like we saw last week those of you
who are here with a very easy win so ok
so you can take the pawn after this move
then what ok you can't allow my keen to
penetrate so kinky sex now it's like
white is being challenged roll all black
wants to do in life is to dance King e6
King b6 and vice versa and how are you
going to make progress once you try to
approach this bond then you might lose
this bond that doesn't look like a wimp
but again by very simple tactical means
White's advances his position look Luke
a one now the rook penetrates from the
side
beautiful of course we know that the
point on f6 is immune because it will
transpose to the variation we just saw a
white will play check trade rooks and
wind upon ending so he tries to free his
rock check here rugby six again a
beautiful move he is not rushing to take
the pawn on d5 that point is not going
anywhere but maybe rooks III might come
to visit right getting the rook active
and maybe winning the beep on so he says
to him I'm first now i'm just ready to
take the poem before then take the pawn
on d5 and that's what actually happens
he played king here trying to stop the
porn hard to suggest anything else
really his hands are tied I'm about to
win both pawns so he played here the
first bomb falls nah we're not giving
any pawns here rook here the second
point falls now it was a good time for
Rubenstein to resign but he's playing by
inertia just for the record i'll show
you how it ended after here here here
here here here one rook is defending the
pawn the king is advancing the other
bond very very simple and here we resign
understood again the placement of the
piece is very important in rock endings
okay now i want to show you to kind of
unique positions that i really really
like one is a composition i'm assuming
because I I don't think it's from a real
game and it goes to show again many
times I'm asked what is better our queen
or two rooks and again it's a very very
individual answer I should give a very
very specific answer it really depends
on the position for example in some
positions the rook are free on open
files many times they can cut off a king
on the last rank two rooks can you
imagine rooks on the 7th and your king
is all the way down then unless the
Queen has some amazing perpetual it's
almost always lost the queen is just
helpless against two months the rooks
like we call pigs under seven and
sometimes the queen is so agile against
clumsy wrote that the rooks are just
unable to withstand the force of the
Queen this
is a beautiful example for that here the
queen is beating the two rocks but you
have to play a series of only moves
because here the difference is not
between a win and a draw but a win and a
loss so let's take a look at the
position materially speaking black is up
material he has 14 points to White's 11
so it's almost like a piece up you think
well that should be easy but the queen
is one the Queen doesn't get nine points
in a raffle the Queen get nine points
because it's a monster piece and here
it's going to show why now every move is
forced but white completely over takes
the position I can tell you that if you
don't play those moves black is going to
consolidate in this position all black
wants to do is get not get made it get
these rooks on open files even if you
end up pitching a pawn let's eat at the
e porn or the a pawn he doesn't really
matter because he has more than enough
pawns so you can imagine if I play
something like let's say in the game
white plays 86 let me play another move
just to show you let's say why play some
random move just to pass on the turn to
black and black is going to play here to
stop this now it's over lost for white
completely because all I want to do is
I'm going to play something like rook e8
and just push my epon if you stop it i'm
going to push my f born my king is
always hiding in the corner and the two
works with the passport even one point
but two points even easier the queen is
no match but like i said it's right to
move and watch what he does first move
86 threatening mate well if you're black
you have an easy no-brainer anything but
g6 is going to go to an early lunch with
tears right so so g6 exactly and now
said said Queen B to again forced
because in this position all I need to
do is play something like f6 black wants
to play something like f six then rook
f7 he is defending the vulnerable 7th
and 8th ranks and then guess what the
other rooks are just going to push those
pawns up no win for white so white plays
the monster move Queen here now again
black has an only move because he's
about to to go if he goes he has to play
e5 he must give the pond they only move
to stop made other movies to play f6 but
problem is that then I'm going to go
queen bee 7 with a double threat I'm
threatening mate and I'm threatening the
local a8 so after the move Rooke f7
Queen takes rook on a eight well this is
just going to win in a very simple way
right I'm winning the rock and my queen
is just going to zigzag close and
there's going to be made so no can do is
get a play he five and again white must
continue with a plan oopsie Queen takes
a five threatening mate again and now F
sex now we see the difference that the
epon was sacrificed so that the Queen
cannot come to be seven and bother the
other look while yet bought this work
wants to defend so of course Queenie
seven rook f7 losses for white so what
does he do Queen d5 check beautiful
again the only move but enough to win
what is the point of this move again we
are forking the king and the rock so
we're not allowing rook f7 become queen
takes rook in the corner mate or not
made but almost made so the only movie
is king here and now Queen B seven
another brilliant move not giving you a
chance to take any control of the
seventh-ranked now black has again and
only move again what is this example
illustrates the strength of the Queen
and the clumsiness of the rocks not a
very fair example but sometimes you do
it to illustrate a point so look here
still I have to tell you black looks
really good in one move i'm going to
play rook from 8 f eight then i'm going
to just send my jeep one and i'm just
going to be okay so white plays the
monster move Queen e7 threatening Queen
f6 shark if you push the f1 then it's
still mate I'm going to go Queenie 5 or
queen of 6 and made so you have to do
this now and now in this specific
position you have to be a little bit
careful you play king a4 if you try to
play h4 looks like your paralyzing the
opponent's pieces because notice the
King can't move the rukon g8 can't move
the rukon f8 can't move the pond can't
move this one can't move in this bone
temper you're not moving a lot of
Jesus but in this position this bond can
move because after pawn takes I'm taking
this pawn with Chuck giving you no time
you see it's a check on the King on a
five so there's no time to take the pond
and then my rook is just going to come
back not ideal so white plays king a
four and now it's over now black is in
zoogs one he loses because after g5 king
a3 kind of funny thing why doesn't do
anything productive it just says to
block ok you do something now keep
making moves good luck and now all of a
sudden he ran out of moves you cannot
move this rock obviously if you move the
rook to g6 i'm going to take on f8 if
you move the rook away if you go to f7 I
take if you move it away from the file
Queen takes f6 is mate the King can't
move this pawn can't move if you go g4
i'll just take it and say thank you very
much if you push the f1 queen e 5 is
mate so basically you'll have to play
something like this then I'm just going
to play King a to you have to keep
pushing then I play King a 3 complete
zoogs mine the powerful Queen just won
the game you have many pieces one two
three four five six seven pieces this
you can't move this you can move legally
everything else just loses so black has
to give up did you understand the
illustration of the Queen strength again
not a very fair position because
sometimes it's the tool rocks are
dominating but that was just a
composition showing the strength of the
Queen ok now I have one of my most
amazing games ever maybe reach this
position this is a game that I played
many many years ago and for many years I
can tell you we analyze this was a very
exciting game and a very exciting ending
and I've analyzed it with my opponent
and several strong players afterwards
nobody came even close to finding the
truth in the position for maybe 10 or 15
years I walked around thinking that I
played almost a perfect game with a
beautifully crafted ending until I put
it in the computer and I put it in the
computer the computer just disagrees not
only disagree with me saying that it was
just a draw in this
it's a draw but the winning plan that I
was playing if I was following it
against what seemed to be a really
foolish plan by black I would have lost
and I can tell you that I would have
played it for sure I would have played
up so let's take a look it's a really
exciting Bishop ending okay even play
black next move just to be in the area
and when you look at it you think well
black is upper pond but his bones are
worthless on the other hand just like we
saw in the previous examples of porn
endings and rook endings White has a
passport on one wing and another
passport on another and you think well
this is looking really awesome right why
it looks like he's just going to win the
game and well that's what I thought as
well I played the obvious Bishop e7 and
now my opponent lost in a very prosaic
way he thought well there's no defense
against bishop f6 that's what I thought
and I thought you know you have no time
to take the pawn on d6 because if you
take the point on b6 let's say then I'm
going to play Bishop f6 you can take
because the King can stop the pond and
when you move the bishop somewhere let's
say here or whatever I will play 86 and
my next move is going to be g 6 and the
pond Queen one of the pawns queen I
thought that's it brilliant right two
pawns against four and I'm winning with
my last one my next move is going to be
another pawn sack and my last one is
going to become a queen this is almost
like a an achievement in minimalism
right unfortunately my calculations were
not right my opponent should have played
the fantastic move Bishop c3 now when I
saw the computer suggested I thought
that they can make I have to change
computers I thought that something is
wrong with my engine I thought I mean
this is such a doofus move there's just
no way that this is going to work what
is what is the idea ok it's kind of nice
if just if i take the bishop then the
point is going to Queen brilliant but
what if I don't take it what is the
point of this how does this help if I
play Bishop f6 and I know that in the
game I would have played Bishop f6 so I
play Bishop f6 against the computer and
I'm saying ok why is this and why is
this a door now he says no it's not a
draw your right you're losing and I'm
like no way there's no how much
how can I lose this position I mean by
King is stopping the pawns and now i
have pawns on both sides of the board
I'm winning what do you mean I'm losing
and then he plays another movement I
almost fell from my chair he played this
my computer suggested this and this is
like from confusion to complete oblivion
what is going on here he just made the
little nook for his bishop then he
closed it right almost like a little
tent and now he zipped it and how does
this help i'm just going to win right so
sure enough i pushed my pawn to 86 i'm
ready to play g6 like in the game right
against the computer and the computer
says well f2 now it kind of started now
it kind of dawned on me now I understood
his evil idea the point was that after
this move only moved to stop the pond is
about to queen with check he is going to
go d3 check ok I gotta take the pawn d2
he's threatening to Queen the pawn must
play here f3 now we see the evil of
bishops III he is defending his porn
that was the purpose of making that
little hiding her little tent and after
my move king d 1 or else on the pond is
going to queen he is going to go f2 and
the computer is right wife is lost just
fantastic I mean I was totally amazed by
descending I even my have a friend who
is a grandmaster in composition and I
sent him this position because I told
them you got to be able to create
something in he said that he's going to
try because really an unusual move
Bishop to c3 think about it oopsie how
often do you see a move like this you're
about to face a disaster of pawns
queening and all of a sudden this Bishop
f6 losing I can still play other moves I
can play for example Bishop back to c5
and that's okay or I can play g6 just
trade my pawns before they are lost and
then it's a drawer you cannot win it but
I cannot win it either if I try to force
the wind like we saw zipping the tent
and now i'm lost it's too late i cannot
fix it any move is going to lead to ft
whatever i do
now is going to redo if I try to play g6
instead that's no solution because again
after here here check and he just takes
my bishop so I lose as well just
incredible I find it to be really really
amazing well I'll show you what happened
in the game very quickly after Bishop g7
Bishop f6 he cannot take so here Bishop
d for that is what i calculated that's
what i thought was the only move now my
bishop is defending my beep on he is
stopping his bones on the f file and now
the wind is really easy he played here i
played here fixing the pawns and he
resigned I mean there's just no defense
against g6 I'm just going to go g6r if
you play let's say king c6 g6 if you
take the h-bond my 86 pawn I will take
on 87 if you take on g6 I will push 87
and my opponent resigned in this
position so thank goodness for computers
finding the truth and endings huh here
is another ending that that kind of
follows what I told you before about the
placement of the pieces and the number
of the pawns this is a very nice ending
meet you between two very strong masses
of the past the play with the white
pieces Frank J Marshall one of the best
American players of all time a great
tactician and Michael chigorin is black
a Russian strong russian grand master
level player and in this position it's
obvious that black has a good position
no question about it we know that the
the fewer pole islands or groups that
you have the better off you are normally
because that means that your pawns are
self-supporting and for example now the
a point is isolated the deep one is
isolated while those pawns are
supporting each other and those pawns
are part of a chain just like this one
and you think hey it's black on the move
what could be simpler than playing rook
c3 check followed by roof takes a three
beautiful right I'm going to be up to
pass pawns on the queenside that has to
win simply but she going nose endings he
knows that this is going to be too much
of a counter play and he played king e6
had he played this kingi for rook takes
a three rooks c2 and the rooks is
rookies coming to the seventh rank all
of a sudden this is not so winning this
is much become much harder maybe not
even winning because the rook is going
to be behind the pawns just like we saw
in my example and the deep one is about
to rush down the board the king is going
to be either away from the arena or cut
off on the last rank and this is
becoming very very difficult now the win
if it even exists is hard to come by so
instead he says well I mean I'm not in a
hurry to take your pawns your pawns are
very weak I'll take them at my leisure
and we played the very strong move king
e6 beautiful again worrying about the
placement of the king closer to the pawn
closer to the center and the Kin the
rook now is not moving from the sea file
not letting white conquered the C file
so white plate rook to be three trying
to save his pawn king d 5 root d3 again
for a moment you say wow material is
even and white managed to kind of patch
things up he's defending all this stuff
but look at the passivity of the rock
this rule cannot make a move and the
king only three again very passive can
hardly move black on the other hand can
just do whatever you want so step one f5
again the idea is that not is going to
be some sort of a because white is
practically in zoosk vine unable to move
his king of rook because he's going to
lose material if he moves the rook from
the file from the from the default he's
going to lose the deep on if he moves
the rook from the rank he's going to
lose the a3 pawn so he tries to he will
try to push his bond and black puts the
first nail in the coffin let's freeze
some bonds h3h five if white was about
to play g4 forget about it no chance so
he has to move the king if you would
have played age for black always has the
move g6 at his disposal so King here
rook takes rook c3 rook check again
asking the king to choose a side are you
going to be cut off are you going to
come straight to me here h4 again
brilliant the key had to let go of the
f1 and now we just break all the pawns
look 2 g's rook to c7 another idea might
have been to take this pawn but of
course after i take this pawn all the
black all the white pawns for after gh4
true cares for and i'm about to take
here here here it's almost like a lesson
in geometry everything just falls apart
so he tries activity and now another
interesting variation if you would have
taken the point immediately then after
rook takes here rook takes here rook
takes g3 king e5 kingi to hear and the
game goes on sure black has good winning
chances but why he's still fighting
instead you just gave him no chance he
went luque for simply realizing that all
those pawns on the Queen and the king
side are not advanced none of them are
about to queen but if he wins the pond
on c3 then he has two runners down the
board on the queenside again not being
greedy so Brooke Chuck trying to force
the key to choose suicide king e for
check king here and he Turk rook takes
rook takes g7 again white is making the
maximum but it's not enough in view of
the runners on the queenside he takes
pawn trying to freeze the pawns but they
just keep advancing ok now on before
rugby 5 yes
as white here ok then I will probably go
ups and stock on then I will probably
play here and after it takes I will just
stay and now again all the pawns are
falling by the time you will play Brooke
you can opt a book g3 if you play
brookie 7 I will just take take and I'm
taking all the pond very very difficult
position and very brilliantly played by
the opponent so let's see what happened
check here check here took took took
here here here here here after be for
Brooke b5 would have frozen the pawns a
little bit and prevented black from
taking the pond on age 5 so he simply
played rugby three beautiful little move
the a pond can run just as well and I'm
not letting the pawn conquer the
fifth-ranked again pass up just making
the rooks position more and more passive
so after rule here rook takes pawn you
let go of my pawn so I can take your own
pawns and now he resigned nothing you
can do about it if you attack any of my
points like if you go route b7 rugby
three rue k7r okay three just beautiful
easy way okay for dessert I'm going to
show you a position I always like to
show a position that is kind of a unique
and unusual I already showed the
position with the five bishops even
though it's really cute so i will show
you this is really really hard i'm going
to show you this one oopsie okay this is
again a composition and it's an ending I
guess it qualifies but i'm not showing
this to ready to learn something but
just to be maybe as I was really amazed
at how beautiful chest can be and yeah
this position white is done material
because black has two nights and four
rock and of course you can take one of
the nights but then you will lose your
passport so like if you play GTX h5
check King takes f7 attacking the rook
and I have lots of porns not to mention
that I'm about to play b2b one protected
by my night why really looks like he's
about to lose the game but watch what
happens really in my opinion one of the
most brilliant compositions I've seen f8
Queen okay that was simple rook takes
now G takes h5 check and in between move
gaining the night before that night
moves King f7 now you say to yourself
well looks like black solved all these
problems because I mean if you trade
rooks right now you will just lose I
mean the point is going to go there's a
pond threatening to grow up to be too
and in any event materially speaking I
have more than enough stuff watch what
he does I don't know can you guess the
next move anybody want to take a guess
it's really really difficult well I'll
show you let's see if you can enjoy it
Luke h8 I know you're looking at me r
just as if I is if I'm drunk but I'm not
i promise you this really is the move
rookie tight and really a beautiful move
now I'm threatening rook f1 mate you
have no time to push the pawn or do
anything with the night because rook f1
now is checkmate so what can you do you
have to take the rook what are the moves
do you have i'm about to go rook f1
check i'm going to be up to rooks so you
take check the king is buried and now
comes another beautiful move before you
start pushing your pawns releasing
yourself h6 again the beauty of chess
white is down and night and two points
in an endgame all he has is a rock but
again the placement look at the place
that the brook is buried in the corner
and now the point of course is if you
play let's see if you play if you take
then of course king here and rook g1
mate is coming so you can take it on the
other hand I'm threatened to play
anyways King here followed by root cafe
check
and what else can you do no way to get
out of the box the night is too late if
you try to bring your night out there
just going to go kini 7 so why twins h6
and wins so Luke h8 really one of the
nicest moves I've ever seen okay guys
thank you very much i enjoyed your time
hope you enjoyed and learn something as
well